والعلاقاتها التركيه المصريه محور وقفه مع
الحدث مع رمضان عطيه اهلا بك يا رمضان
اهلا رجاء مصفحه ورغبه ببدايه جديده تاتي
طبعا بعد سنوات من القطيعه والخلافات
العميقه بين بلدين نعود ربما على هذه
الحقبه التي ميزت سنوات الماضيه منذ
الاطاحه من جانب الجيش المصري الرئيس مرسي
بطبيعه الحال لم تكن العلاقات خلال
السنوات الاخيره همم يعني جيده بل كانت
سيئه جدا ولكن بدايه فنبدا الرجاء بهذه
الصوره التي وصفها البعض بانها تاريخيه
صوره هذه المصافحه بين الرئيس اردوغان
والرئيس السيسي هذه الصوره التي نراها
وامير قطر شيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني بينهما
همم واضح بان الامور جاءت بواسطه قطريه
ويعني هذا الترحاب القطري وهذه المناسبه
التي تم فيها لقاء شخص انت تدل على انها
همم لم تكن صدفه او لم تكن وليده اللحظه
همم هناك مؤشرات تقول بان همم تقارب
التركي المصري بدا قبل فتره الرئيس التركي
بدايه هذه الصوره سربتها الرئاسه التركيه
وحين عودته في طائره عندما عاد من قمه ال
20 في بالي الرئيس ارجوك ان قال بانه يريد
او يطمح الى التقارب من مصر ومن سوريا ثم
قبل هذه القمه كانت هناك لقاءات قبل اسبوع
من هذه المصافحه التاريخيه كانت هناك
لقاءات على مستوى اجهزه الاستخبارات بين
البلدين الحديث عن سبل العمل للتقريب بين
البلدين ثم كان هناك لقاء لافت على هامش
قمه شرم الشيخ لقاء رسمي على هامش قيمه
المناخ في 27 بين وزير الخارجيه المصري
وزير البيئه وتخطيط العمراني التركي همم
واذا همم هذه
الخطوات توضح بان هناك طلب تركي منذ العام
للتوسط ولتقارب مع القاهره الجديد في هذه
الصوره هو قبول القاهره بهذا سنرى لماذا
لكن اذا عدنا
لتدهور العلاقات كانت بسبب الاطاحه بمرسي
على يد السيسي في الثالث من يوليو تموز
لعام همم 2013 اردوغان وصف السيسي
لعام 2014 بانه طاغيه فبالتالي هناك
احتقان بين الرجلين لعام 2016 عندما تمت
محاوله الانقلاب على اردوغان من قبل جماعه
عبد الله همم قول همم
اردوغان اتهام مصر بالوقوف في وراء هذه
الجماعه وبدعمها في العام 2017 مصر القت
على 29 شخص
تتهمهم بالتجسس لصالح تركيا فبالتالي
العلاقات كانت متازمه جدا طيب ماذا بعد
هذه المصافحه وهل بربونات الامور او تعكس
اتفاقا بين البلدين لم يظهر الى العلم بعد
هناك صفقه اكيد لان القاهره لن تقبل بهذا
التحول بدون مقابل هناك صفقه بدات باتجاه
تركيا الى نجم انتقادات الاخوان المسلمين
همم ايضا في ليبيا هناك بعد دخول اذن
تركيا على خط الحرب لدعم طرابلس في مواجهه
حفتر كان هناك اذا فشل لحفتر وربما تلتقي
مصر والقاهره حول الملف الليبي لكن قضيه
الغاز في الشرق المتوسطيه العقده التي
ربما هناك مؤشر على عقد صفقه فيها لماذا
لان تركيا يعني انها اتجهت الى التنقيب في
شرق المتوسط
قامت القائمه حول ذلك همم وقعت اذا
اتفاق مع ليبيا لتنقيب عن الغاز في شرق
المتوسط في سياق الحرب الاوكرانيه وفي
سياق ازمه الطاقه وفي سياقه هروله اسرائيل
ولبنان
لتنقيب على الغاز من مصلحه تركيا اليوم
الانضمام الى نادي المنقبين عن الغاز في
شرق المتوسط
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه التركي تفيد بان
تركيا تعرض على مصر حصه اكبر من تلك التي
تعرضها اليونان فبالتالي همم مصر ايضا
محتاجه للخبرات التركيه للتنقيب عن النفط
في شرق المتوسط وبالتالي يمكن ان نقول بان
الهجرسي الاقتصادي وهارجس التنقيب عن
النفط فيس عايز ازمه الغاز وازمه الدوليه
الى التي قربت بين الرجلين وبين العدوين
السابقين صح التعبير شكرا